all right my awesome tacular rights here
it is that thing that you've wanted me
to talk about it's really funny people
like where's your Logan spoiler video
and I'm doing my looking spoiler video
frantically and I'm editing in this
Deadpool video hits the internet people
are like well forget about the Logan
spoiler video now we want Deadpool
sorry guys you're getting both Logan
videos already yeah it's just you have
to check that one out but this Deadpool
video was to me it was at the beginning
of Logan not the screening the screening
didn't have this and it was on the
beginning of Logan when I saw it at the
movie theater you know on Friday morning
and it didn't really look like a trailer
it looked like a Pixar short you know
how the Pixar animations have that Pixar
short at the beginning it was kind of
like in the vein of that but you know
Deadpool it was just kind of at the
beginning of Logan it takes place in
front of a Logan movie theater Ryan
Reynolds posted it not calling it
Deadpool - trailer than everyone else
opposed to calling it a Deadpool -
trailer so I guess it's a Deadpool - ish
trailer even though at the end of this
video it doesn't say Deadpool - coming
not soon enough
it says Deadpool coming not soon enough
what is this is absolutely a marketing
campaign for Deadpool - so let's talk
about that man that was the longest
intro ever for a trailer video so this
thing starts out this old dude is
getting mugged and then it shows someone
in a hoodie and he takes out the ear
buds it pulls back the hood and it's
dead bull without his mask with his
crusty ass [ __ ] up face he's like not
on my watch [ __ ] and he runs to
this phone booth and singing the super
this Superman theme is playing the
entire time
old-school John Williams Superman theme
it's great Fame in the vein of Superman
he's can be changed in a phone booth and
it's just taking forever you hear this
old man getting mugged over here calling
for help please please please in debt
he's just taking the layers of clothing
off and then putting the layers of
clothing on and it's taking an awkward
amount of time to do it which is funny
because that's the old joke the old joke
but not the fact that it's a phone booth
and as I said at the end of this video
he's like weren't those things wiped out
in 1998 but I remember being a kid going
only Superman could ever get dressed in
a phonebook Superman or the flash
everyone else it would take way too long
the crime would happen and sure enough
that's what happened he finally gets his
Deadpool outfit on did you hear this he
freezes and he opens it up he goes over
there the dudes dead Stanley says
something he basically says shut up
Stanley and it goes running over there
to the dude who's now dead he's like oh
man yeah you were not gonna come back
from that very simple trailer dudes
getting mugged
Deadpool sees it happen goes to the
phone booth to get changed takes a long
time doing it dude
get shot Deadpool gets out and then lays
down on the dudes stomach using his
stomach as a pillow while he eats his
Ben & Jerry's ice cream but even for
Deadpool pretty [ __ ] up dude probably
had a family dick the great thing is I
saw this YouTube commenter in the
comment section of one of the channels
that has this trailer out said something
like Peter Parker becomes spider-man
because Uncle Ben was killed in a
robbery because Deadpool didn't stop it
now these are two different Studios
doing those two different properties
deadpool and spiderman so i mean that's
not me i don't think but it really made
me go holy [ __ ] wouldn't that be amazing
even if it's thematically they're like
we can't use the name Uncle Ben but
that's totally supposed to be Uncle Ben
anyhow that concept just cracked me up
you know what going forward that's what
I'm saying I'm saying spider-man
homecoming Peter Parker became
spider-man because this happened then
there's this text a speedrun that crawls
up the screen I just do not have the
patience to rate them to be honest with
me but anyhow this dude cracked me up it
was some good dark comedy in the vein of
Deadpool marketing it's just great to
see the first step in Deadpool to
marketing can wedge this right in there
among all the cable casting rumors out
there so guys the Deadpool 2 trailer
video footage prologue thingamajig have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]